the casablanca hotel in north las vegas
is being shut down at least for now
north las vegas police telling 8 news
now the property which is on las vegas
boulevard and kerry
was given a letter yesterday from code
enforcement to stop
all operations by noon today so as you
take a look at this video here the doors
are now shuttered
and police tape surrounding the building
we're still though working to clarify
what exactly the violations are now the
current owner who according to the clark
county assessor was
who owned the property since july told
us the city actually had issues with the
previous owner but wouldn't tell us what
those issues were
the previous owner was las vegas dragon
hotel llc
now if that sounds familiar it's because
they also own the alpine motel
that's a where fire broke out last year
killing six people
now the people displaced today from the
casablanca overnight were
offered services and also free
transportation to new locations
from police and also help of southern
nevada